okay so today we're going to look at
hook to public
yeah we're not actually gonna go into
everything we notice that the notes that
I provided you with all the things that
we focused on you have to do with the
first part of the book and there is some
other things discussed at the after this
discussion between Logan and his brother
and Socrates after they raised this
problem what else do they talk about in
this book there's really two other
sections it jumps to Socrates making
this metaphor this analogy saying the
city is like the human being but we're
going to get to that more when we get
before if you can look at big letters
for instance if you want to figure out
what justice is all you see this is
easily on the board it's not your small
friend I think it's too small for some
of the back row right Socrates says
isn't it a lot easier if you have to
look at something if you look at big
letters and this is the same thing
though as this if we look at justice in
the city maybe that will tell us
something about justice and individual
and then he goes into this long thing
about how does a city form you know you
first have to supply food so some people
are farmers and what else to choose so
some people cobblers houses some people
have to be builders carpenters whatever
you want to call it and yeah the city of
merges out of this process of exchange
satisfying each other's needs why does
he bring that up that's going to direct
something that we're going to talk about
this problem
egos
pays for the individual then after that
he goes into this famous passage where
he condemns the poets where he wants to
criticize and when you see poets like I
said last time whenever they're reading
Plato or Aristotle or any of these
really thinkers and you see poets think
media think entertainment so television
the music industry what else
stuff on the internet anything that
where where there's some artistic
production and it's there to scare
people like you know like the tragedy
does we're gonna pull up their
heartstrings or make them you know laugh
abuse them like comedies to entertain in
other ways like I guess reality shows
and somebody's gonna make you laugh make
you feel tragic but you know some people
you watch them out of morbid curiosity
right any of those sorts of things would
be with the poets Socrates wants to kick
the poets out of the ideal city why does
he want to do that we're not going to
talk about that much of a the really
simple answer is they portrayed the
wrong things and then people get the
wrong ideas so one way to deal with that
is censor them right tell them you can
stay here but you can only present this
sort of thing why does he do that well
we're going to talk about that a little
bit later when we look at how is justice
court record because in Socrates view
and actually in golovkin an animatic you
the poets are doing a really lousy job
in portraying justice not any worse than
parents or teachers are but you know
they're making it even worse they're
reinforced they're making it part of the
culture so that's where we're headed
this is the question that this
this concern what kind of good is
justice and you know as Balkan is
actually doing a lot of documents it's
not just socrates glaucon says there's
three kinds of goods and I'm going to
use some terminology that globba didn't
use in this that I think you'll find
helpful well let's look at just what he
says there's there's goods that we want
or designer or a value or their own
stake what are some examples of those
the things that give us pleasure to
write things that make us feel good give
us joy if you're into listening to
certain kinds of music you listen to the
music for any other purpose than
listening to music you just like
listening to the people makes me happy
maybe angry you like they hang or
and what are some examples of this you
talked about medicine right not an
entirely GAAP thing because when I was a
kid they started doing something that's
not common practice which is making
making medicines taste good and it used
to be before like for my parents
generation medicines uniformly tasted
awful yeah you know that's why there's
that old song because it's matter of
fact if any of you experimented with
drinking various liquors and you the
ones that are made with herbs and you
can you drink them you know I'm holy
well this is awful
how can people drink this stuff those
were originally medicines they were
their words that were preserved for the
medicinal properties and the only way to
preserve them was an alcohol and
eventually people started you know
drinking it for fun but some of them
still tastes pretty pretty awful for you
guys
but it's Madison a good thing
what's it good for nobody eg aspirins
for their own sake takes penicillin
just for fun what do we do what's a good
you know health is a good and sometimes
we're not healthy so we have to take
medicine to restore our health some some
people take medicine as it preventive
you know like they do things like drink
cod liver oil which I've never had and
why we do them just for the sake of
something else
what about money it's money particularly
valuable for its own sake if you think
it is I mean some some banknotes are
pretty people collect them what good is
money well they can give you other
things other things which we actually
value for their own sake and then there
is and we value them because they've
produced those other same things we
value other goods over here in this
category without any goods here for the
sake of something else because those
things produce those things
so think about exercise now how many of
you really really enjoy exercise there's
probably a few right should you exercise
even if you don't really
like it why it's healthy yeah it's gonna
produce health gets more and more
importantly older than you get so you
can you know keep a toe on and you know
lift weight so that your bones you know
stay stay firm my parents supposed to
help you when you get older these kind
of goods are productive so we have to go
with its winds that are valued for their
on the sink goods middle that are valued
for their own sink and also productive
of other goods the goods that we don't
really want for their own sake but we we
do want because they bring about other
things and there's a couple terms that
you can use business this we can call
instrumental these goods are
instrumental in bringing about other
this I'm gonna be like following the
speed limit to them to the letter doing
exactly this people nobody in here not a
single person enjoys following this be
how many do follows I'm going to be at
least stick with them you know ten miles
of speed in here why should you even if
they don't happen to you it's not a fun
place to be there's other good reasons
writer to me you should probably go to
speed limit so you don't hit a deer in a
person or go off the road most probably
like to drive faster and probably do
some you know risky maneuver is like
those are instrumentalist Energon we
call intransigence the trinsic Goods
kathirvel you in themselves and this
could vary from person to person right
one person might steal wealth rightly as
a merely instrumental good
the miser sees well as intrinsic good
that's what's wrong with the plants
right that's why they hold on to time
they do wealth they don't realize that
it's only instrumental good on these
goods in the middle of the people
intrinsic and instrumental now some
Goods could actually be intrinsic in
some cases and instrumental in other
cases or for different people think
about friendships you have some friends
that even if you didn't get anything
from them like getting invited to
parties or they help you study they paid
off for dinner or things like that by
the first round drinks all the time
you still want to be with them because
you can enjoy
yes okay good
that print would be an intrinsic good
the friendship that you share with the
intrinsic good other people you may have
relationships with and you're friendly
with them but you know you don't really
like the England then you get something
from them maybe you know that sort of
relationship with me right now helping
you through a class you'd be great at
the end hopefully I'm communicating the
good of knowledge to you and also you
come out of here knowing something more
than you came in hopefully if that's the
case but I would be just a instrumental
though right our relationship would be
an instrumental relationship when you go
to a restaurant are you friends with all
of your servers you might become friends
but you really want them just to bring
your food you know whatever it is that
you're gonna drink and then leave you
alone right maybe after a while you
relationship with the server and you
feel obligations in both ways maybe you
know and then he's in the middle
logged-in says these are the most
valuable these are the things like
health a friendship could be something
like this - you know I have some
friendships that go back a long ways
mostly in my family yeah I like being
with those people but you know when you
actually get into a tough situation
that's when you they say that's when you
find out who your real friends are your
friend is an instrumental good at that
time your friend is providing something
and they're probably in this category
they're valued for their own sake we're
also valued because they're productive
overall the next health is like being
able to see is like that these are all
goods knowledge is probably something
that fits in there as well there's some
knowledge that's just useful knowledge
there's some things that are worth
knowing for their own sake there are
some things that
the light for their own sake that also
turn out to be useful
so we have all these different kinds of
goods what are those things that would
fit into what would be some other
examples what are some things you like
just for the occasional watching TV is
yeah I mean when we watched movies bad
but like educational TV might it's just
you're kind of getting the information
that's not really enjoyable pretty yeah
it's it's surprising not a lot of
educational some could could be done
entertaining
I spent time sometimes watching
everything for skip comedy sketch comedy
so I'll watch Adam or Comedy Central or
college humor because I get a kick out
of I'm not actually getting anything
good I just enjoy them educational TV I
do end up watching once that I do you
end up watching a lot of educational
stuff and you know so there's a lot of
videos that I don't post for you and
either because they are so so boring
that I get bored and I have like this
well that's a good example yeah to some
degree I mean I know mostly from the
looking for you guys to give me examples
that necessarily hold for everybody what
are you actually put in these categories
but you do actually a lot of our
listening to music is not done because
we think it's improving our character or
it's going to make us rich or something
that we do cuz we like music
yeah maybe working out it could be in
the middle yeah that's that's what this
and that relativity would apply to that
as well feels like I'm not a shape so
and I do actually that's what I get to
hack into shape a long time and when you
first start working out what's it like
somebody said oh it hurts
right it gets really sorry afterwards
you're winded while you're doing it you
know you don't want to go to the gym
because sometimes you feel like you know
these are these are couple things maybe
a deaf way it's merely instrumental you
can eat but you know it's good for you
know if I go and do cardiovascular
activity
30 minutes a day to improve everything
for me like energy but I he and actually
part of the reason why I had mama shaped
like this when I was your age
thanks to workout three hours a day
because I'm really enjoying all that
bodily activity and then I got the word
it shifted from being good luck this
just working out is not just yeah be
productive of other things like finding
a mate right
I love sometimes about music - you think
music fits in here music can help like
during your workout oh that's
interesting
yeah I suppose yeah a lot of people
sometimes music gets people okay yeah
okay that's that's a good maybe maybe
we'll put exercise is to recognize the
validity of the fact that not everybody
sees it the same way
we're some other things that we don't
like but we put up with her pursuer do
because they bring about
you guys probably don't enjoy doing
homework and I don't actually drink
reading you know thinking about this for
every assignment that you do I get why
do we do it well because it does produce
it and the good is knowledge or learning
education but yeah it's sort of like he
talks about medicine our medicine tastes
pretty good right that wasn't always the
case when I was a kid some medicines
tasted good and some tasted awful now
they all pretty much taste good but he
used to me yes the business takes a walk
that's why the discipline is a term of
approach if you're describing the wine
dishes yeah but what does medicine give
you well they don't figure I'm gonna die
if you don't take it now dang those are
good being all these are good what else
there's some other things that we yeah
yeah oh I can give you eventually to
move from here to here with reading
Plato put it here all you've worked
right how many of you get a job to me
almost all how many you had jobs that
you really enjoyed not all of it
hopefully all of you will eventually
have jobs that fit in here so let us put
down let's let's make a contrast here
career and job well well job is doing
stuff that you know you can take it or
leave it you do it just to earn money
right it's not what you really prefer to
be doing but with a career you can
actually put yourself into it and you
can you can get some satisfaction and
doing so it's what you feel calling to
do enjoy you've been thinking about all
the trim things like for me reading
Plato is one of the side benefits of the
career at the half because reading Plato
can affect me and I get something out of
it I'm not really play off funny stories
and twist endings but I'm not actually
improving my mind
no Henry but I am both reading reading
Plato same thing with your job over here
job happens to be yeah it could be
something as mundane as you know if you
think about it some of the people that
are here that are janitorial staff here
they do a pretty important thing because
if they never got strike they're not
unionized but let's say they didn't
you'd be amazed how much how much crap
piles of waffle place it looks with that
just in a couple of days they do a
really important service
so most people do janitorial stuff
they're not particularly fun how many of
you have ever worked as janitors yeah
that's I'm not a janitor now alright
you're not studying at the janitor yeah
most of us aren't into that sort of
thing
for some people it could be some people
enjoy actually tidying things up it's a
productive good to make some money
now everybody's clear about that right
so three different kinds of goods what's
the question blob could have Socrates
why is he bringing up all the goods
what kind of good is justice is it
something that's valuable for its own
sake this is something that's not only
valuable for its own sake but also
because of the benefits it produces
where is it something that we value just
because it produces things that we like
but we don't really like justice itself
what we mean by justice doing the right
thing right so now think about this do
you want other people to be just do you
want them to do the right thing and you
want the doing it which kind of world
yeah we wear people to the right thing
right so you can count on that and then
steal your things they won't break into
your house they kill you they you know
you look at them the wrong way
it's like justice is productive of good
things like social order harmonious life
freedom from fear and even so we do
value for the sake of other things do we
value it for its own sake the people say
to themselves it's really important to
me that I have justice
some people do everybody clearly we
would need in prisons police closer to
see Jake
why do people act justly is it is it why
do they want justice for themselves is
it because they just want to get by that
would be an instrumental good right they
don't want to get punched maybe it's all
the people who praise them and say nice
things about them that would be
instrumental if justice is going to be
an insurance of good we've got to be
able to say what benefit it is to the
person who has it not just that they
were able to get blockless which is very
important for the ancient Greeks or have
a lot of friends or have people like
that have a good reputation do business
well you know there's some people for
example those are business majors that
think about the big push these days -
you know sustainability and ethics and
people making the claims that ethical
business is good business treats your
bottom line well you know there's
something to that right I'm not I'm not
knocking that by the way I'd much rather
than ethical business people who are
motivated by the idea that probably the
mistaken in yet then it'll improve their
bottom line then a bunch of cutthroat
you know tear everything down and sell
it business types that would be
preferable but it is looking at justice
is just intrinsic good isn't it did you
do the right thing not because it's the
right thing not because doing the right
thing actually is valuable in and of
itself preferable lot of good you should
do the right thing because when you do
the right thing it increases your bottom
line it provides you benefits that's not
much different than doing the right
thing so you can get along with
that's not much different than being a
kid and doing the right thing so mom and
dad either don't you know back in
or you know maybe they give you candy
you're just being an ethical business
person because it's going to improve
your bottom line from a moral
perspective it's really no different
than being a kid who behaves in a good
way so that he gets more candy and King
you know it's all looking at justice is
just an instrumental feather and there
are a lot of people who do look at it
this way right Lakhan talks about this
yeah here's where we get to two
different moral theories one of them is
called egotism and he who isn't says
that human beings should do the ethical
thing to do is to look out for your own
interests and you can look out for other
people's interests provided they
coincide with your own or you know by
looking out for them it's gonna help you
right egos doesn't have to be a you know
just a complete selfish person but
they're ultimately selfish and justice
for an egoist can only be instrumental
why be just so you don't think published
but you know if you have a chance to be
unjust why not be unjust if there were
no consequences for you being unjust do
it another soul another theory that
we're going to look at and we're only
gonna get out of early today is contract
arianism and thomas hobbes talks about
this and some other people that we're
not reading this semester also talk
about this contract Arianism begins from
an egoist and when it says look if we're
all really selfish how can we get past
that because if we are all really
selfish we're probably not going to be
just to each other we're probably not
going to
I think maybe what we need here's what's
called contract here there's something
like a swinging contract a general
agreement I'll keep my hands off and
your stuff and you keep your hands off
of my stuff
I won't threaten you or kill you or
cheat you or lie to you and you won't do
those to me and that will keep order and
that will allow us all to enjoy a pretty
good life a better life than if we were
all competing with each other all the
time I'm trying to get over at each
other that still looks at justice as
just an instrument so good
exactly
then all of you hear what she said
that's a very good way of putting it
egoism candies saccharin as a moral
theory from contractors we could all say
let's all be eager us I'll pursue my
interests my good and that coincides
there is great if not gonna be done
playing each other or fraud or contract
arianism is a moral theory requires
egoism as its basis but then it tries to
go past it so it's sort of twisting so
often is putting forward is actually a
contract here interviewing he doesn't
buy it himself but he wants to see
Socrates address them and it's one of
the most eloquent statements of them in
the ancient world that's why we're
looking at so how does he frame is he
brings up this famous story of guidance
we've all read it so I'm not going to
rehearse it guy just finds a ring and
what's this one he puts the ring on and
what happens to him
poof he turns invisible and then he does
some bad things kills the King steals
his wife you know it looks like he has a
pretty happy life though right he starts
out as a shepherd back in ancient times
you know being a shepherd was not a lot
of fun that was sort of the entry-level
job you know like working in the mail
stinking sheep all the time being
outside
rained up and then if you don't miss him
and they beat you so not a lot of fun
then he makes it to be king right did he
did he succeed in that by being just
look out there other than having to
bring him injustice exactly what's up he
is unjust and he sort of when a person
is its person is unjust and injustice is
the characters
so yeah he does that precisely because
he's on jobs so here's where we have to
think about some of these these
questions let's say you he had a ring
what would you do
what are some of the things that a lot
of times you know people want us and we
aren't able to take revenge this would
allow you to do whatever sort of revenge
you want from you know things like
dancing them in public to maybe throwing
them down a wall you know whatever you
want to do
yeah I said I look like do good things
but for like strictly well like you know
I mean they keep going to cover so I can
show you wanted criminal just for the
money purposes to get a zero hold of it
and you would get money from that like
turning situations to your own vigilante
you would have your magic ring baby
would being stronger than anyone else
but there would be a significant
advantage
Oh
there are some people that is like
killing imagine one of them gets a ring
you know usually they more or less keep
it under wraps because they're worried
about claw and you know they're doing
you know cried there's the cover about
this person can tell me when they want
yeah maybe for ransom maybe some people
should drink it down do you know that
some of the guys that I used to teach
kidnapping yeah think about them in
which somebody has to do the ring that
turns invisible or there's a watch that
stops time or any of these sorts of
ploys and not the kids these ones you
know what's really the first person that
person doesn't watch go into the locker
room of the opposite sex and start
checking out naked bodies right the part
cuz it gets laughs but it hurt because
you know anything else this is content
you're more worried that other people do
terrible things right although you know
if it came down to it we we would be
hard for us sometimes especially if we
had the ring for a long time not to do
terrible things be easy to indulge
ourselves but we know that there's some
other people out there who clearly we
don't want to have that sort of power
some of them actually have done these
things already some of them have done
them many times
let's look at some of your answers what
would you do yeah I would go to places
that I'm not allowed to get into I would
say look like places that I've never
been here I would never pay for anything
to go in anywhere again I'd watch the
movies on it museums the White House you
what yeah you didn't direct anyone I
know there's something there's something
strangely calming about making all these
circuits and seeing everything the same
length I don't know what it is but
there's something strangely sense
seems pretty innocent right but why why
do we refrain from doing it well
generally because people don't like us
listening it up right like you don't
necessarily like have to steal we do
anything bad thing but you guys like
what's called insider information and
use that information to make money it
was unethical but it's not necessarily a
farming anyone's directly you know you
can think of all sorts of cases like
let's say you are you are a rival with
somebody else for the same dieting or
girl and you're able to set things up in
such a way as they're gonna trip and
fall because they can't see whatever it
is it's you know do things like that
embarrass them so when you come out on
top maybe your business or office and
you embarrass your
competitor my screwing up his report
just as he's giving it in front of the
big boys it's like you do all sorts of
things it's like to carry or it was it's
when the guy from the office was the
news reporter Bruce Almighty in some way
yeah I didn't think of that that that
would be a good example of somebody
given this kind of power right yeah
there's other ones were rings or things
well think about like for the Lord of
the Rings but that one in that case love
the ring does have some consequences
because you put it on and suddenly these
horrifying creatures can nobody else can
see you they can see you they're gonna
try to kill you so that's not good some
of these what are you afraid other
people with dudes you or your loved ones
yeah well what he said about like
setting up situations I put down that I
would be afraid that like people were
going so I think tomorrow said like
about the CIA like going to like like
what makes reason and stuff like that
okay and espionage
reason okay
what about on a personal level people
could be doing that with you spying on
you I mean think about this
we have prisoners right and we put
people in prisons for doing unjust
things those people did those things
even when there were laws and sanctions
in place imagine that some of these
people are doing guys yeah he would just
he would that would be its full-time job
you just go around killing there's
there's some people who just like doing
bad things so that people whatever what
are some of the other
yeah how many of you have done somebody
wrong or at least they think that you've
done wrong to them when I like I think
about things like that I just don't get
them because well I think about it and
like that's wrong and also worried about
like what would happen to me for my why
yeah there is a sanction okay the a lot
of the reasons why we don't do unjust
things that were tempted to do is
because we would lose out on some
benefit that we like or there'd be some
sort of punishment no no I'm just like
right now because my roommate keeps
parking in my spot
I get really annoyed and I actually said
bitterly don't [ __ ] my spot and we're
not like close friends or anything dr. Q
all I I don't know I don't know but I I
would never do anything I would never
but like I was like laughs it was so bad
it was like I'm just really put a nail
buy your time but I would never do that
because I keep scared that I would get
tired guys in school or something no
other people but I could I would never
I'm too nervous we're actually I feel
like that there's a lot of combination
to it like I would never do anything
like steel or like any of these bad
things are wearing that other people do
yeah I mean most of it is coming from
Pharma but than others just find more
else it's not really I have no reason to
do anything okay well I was gonna add
like for example let's say it was
mentioned that you're gonna rob a mint
where they produce money mm-hmm maybe
necessarily you wouldn't describe it but
maybe you would rather it you give money
to the poor
yeah organization you could do good
things with the ring the reason why I
bring up the bad things free and more
dangerous
that's interesting that one yeah that
one's never been brought up in a class
that I thought it wouldn't be that I'm
doing something bad necessarily but you
wouldn't you would be losing out the
reason why I focused on all that stuff
here
his biggest blocking us with the ring of
magnets what is what he did
he chose the King steals the Queen
becomes super rich does all sorts of bad
things anybody we didn't why he could
kill what happens in movies when people
have this was the first thing that they
typically do if it's now the kids moving
sneaking to somebody's you know locker
room look at people with being the
opposite sex right probably another one
this is a con tenancy you're more
worried than other people do terrible
things than that humans right although
you know if it came down to it we we
would be hard-pressed sometimes
especially we had the ring for a long
time not to do terrible things the easy
to indulge ourselves but we know that
there's some other people out there who
clearly we don't want to have that sort
of power some of them actually have done
these things already some of them have
done them many times
so why we need justice well we need
justice love it says to protect us from
what would happen if we let people do
whatever they wanted we don't value
justice for its own sake we value it
because it protects us from people who
would do this sort of stuff and what do
we have to do we have to give up doing
this sort of stuff oh we might like to
do you know let's take something fairly
innocent like the eavesdropping I like
that I think people are saying but I
don't willing to give up the
eavesdropping if they're willing to give
up killing me that's a pretty good
trade-off right I'm willing to give up
taking the sort of her advantage that I
often like to take thankfully less often
and I'm willing to give that up if
people won't do this sort of stuff to me
or the people that have that I care
about that's a contract here in a way of
looking at justice it's not that justice
by itself is a good thing that's a it's
not an intrinsic good it's an
instrumental bit it's good for me
because it keeps all of you from doing
bad things to me it's good for you
because it keeps everybody else and
myself from doing bad things to you
that's what Malkin says is the origin of
justice what do you think about this
does this seem plausible
you know people who think along these
lines is you know if I have a chance
hell yeah I would do bad stuff I don't
have a chance I think everybody should
obey the rules
yeah that was lankans those acquitted
blocking speech again Lumpkin doesn't
actually believe this but he's say he
Socrates a lot of people say this
what's your response and I think in his
society that was a case and they get our
society that's the case too and then you
can probably call to mind a few people
you can call to mind some people who
said stuff like this in your experience
and you are hearing they may have
actually said this is the way you want
to think about this there are certain
professions where this is more of a risk
another thing to think about before we
go on from granddaddy's what else we
don't have a brings of invisibility
further at all and putting the site to
no sci-fi things like a watch that can
stop time or you know some sort of
substance that'll turn you invisible or
things like that do we have anything
that gives people that we have any
situations there's hackers right yeah
all of you probably know the thing from
the friend stranded in London who needs
money at one point or another yeah
and then sometimes you know if somebody
leaves their Facebook open I see this
I've had about 400 friends or so so on
any given day one of them has probably
done something done with their Facebook
and then you know they'll see somebody
write something and you're like oh
that's that's not what they think and it
will give you something to write
you've all seen these things right what
happens and some of these are Facebook
opening their roommate with a friend or
sometimes the husband of the wife comes
in it's just starts raining crazy stuff
and they say I think you've been hacked
did you leave your thing open so yeah
there's there's that happen that could
actually be pretty damaging what else so
there's there's access to people's
passwords or personal information I
guess identity any other cases where
somebody has that kind of power or you
or somebody else they can act
yeah this is the problem for any
protective service so it's a problem
with policing it's a problem with
prisons it's a problem in the military
by their very nature if they're gonna
function they have to be given quite a
bit of latitude there will always be
some for up soldiers cops prison guards
in any given population so they're
always going to be some abuse estate you
know if you're your maximum security
prison yeah there's not cameras watching
you and you use a prisoner the prisoner
complaints it's their word in there a
prisoner they're a convicted criminal
against against yours
once you've already gotten a lot of
complaints in your background internal
affairs is investigating
you'll probably get away with it so
that's where the power can can lend
itself to the corrupt you know there's
that statement power corrupts absolute
power corrupts absolutely power corrupts
precisely because people aren't able to
handle what comes with it the temptation
is to use them and if you if your view
is that the only reason why you should
be judged and so other people don't look
bad or the punishment it's going to be
very difficult to resist those kind of
temptations look at the other cases like
you know some of these blocks being
somebody's boss can often the position
of immense power you control their
career
access they have two resources I mean
this is how we get into situations where
bosses coerce employees into you know
say working late on the weekends on one
hand at one extreme and sexual
relationships that they don't want to be
in on the other extreme and everything
in between these situations of power
what goes wrong is that the person who
has the power has a certain idea of
justice they don't see justice as
something we're having for its own sake
they see it as just an instrument so
good and if you remove the consequences
that's what the ring does it removes
consequences that removes their if
they're the reason for being just and so
they must let's look now since we don't
have a little bit more that the the
argument that he had a mantis toboggan
together so we're shifting down to
something else they say everybody in our
society when they're talking about
justice
they don't praise it for its own sake
they
now how can you tell how somebody sees
this one way is to give them power right
give them a little bit of power and see
what they'll do with it
that's why it can be sometimes useful to
set up experiments where you make
somebody think that they've actually got
power over somebody else watch to see
whether they have use it or not if they
abuse it you don't want that person
working as a cop or a prison guard or as
a soldier perhaps not even as a nurse or
a doctor right what are other things you
can do when you could look at what
people actually sing you don't have to
set up experiments just look at what
people actually sing about it do they
everybody says justice is a good thing
do they say it's a good thing because
it's worthwhile the gambits it's a high
value in and of itself it's something
that makes the person who has it
actually better it makes their life
better even if you took away the other
stuff or are they praising it because
it'll bring you nice things Logan and
Anna mantas they say that most people
see justice as merely instruments
dependence it's not a good in itself
doing the right thing is valuable only
because you know leads to the
consequences for you where are these
ideas come
how the parents and teachers actually
talked about doing the right thing if we
take most attention I think raising
doing the right thing because it's a
good thing in and of itself because
having a good character is not just
something nice for other people but good
for you as such where do they talk about
it in terms of rewards and punishments
why do your parents want you to be a
good person you turn like reward or a
little yeah cuz they don't get it and
you have to say well if you do this I'll
punish you you don't like being punished
right so I'll do these and I my
four-year-old boy I remember this really
interesting moment little kids don't
have much impulse but they develop self
consciousness over time and I remember
there was something I don't I don't know
exactly what the thing was but I told
them you better not do this again or
you're gonna get punished you understand
that right and what he said was I hope I
don't do that like he like you know
maybe well maybe he doesn't completely
have control he really hopes
but you know his impulses are not
entirely up to him and it could go they
could go this way already and he was so
earnest about it you know but yeah so
when we're teaching it to kids we walk
and have to put things in terms of you
know rewards or punishments if you're if
you're mean to people they're not gonna
let you tell me that's right they're not
gonna play if you're a good boy or good
girl the people are going to like you
play the teachers you'll get by and that
is what this time goes on
some of us give mean away from that
others keep hearing these sorts of
things like you know if you're a good
and I think Oh businessman then you'll
make one month that's not saying that
it's good to actually be ethical and
saying that the bottom line will improve
if you're out and for a lot of people
they'll say well my bottom line to
improve that's what I really care about
they better behave in this this manner
if it doesn't turn out to be the case
that's for everybody I'm gonna do what I
want to do punishments you know
eventually we really bad things we put
you in prison
lockup we're hurt sometimes you do other
things in some societies they cut off
the hands of these lash people
there's a big case about about 10 years
ago they're really chewing gum they have
in some places to parents and teachers
walk and do talk this way you'd better
learn the material because the material
is worth learning otherwise I'm going to
flunk you that's killing to a punch
right you learn the material really
bottom to give you a day that's telling
you there's some sort of war for him
right that's not saying that that's an
intrinsic good
who else there's a problem so talks
about another he calls him the poets
because that's what they were called but
we should see this a bit more blindly
when he says poets whenever you see
poets in Plato or Aristotle or really
any ancient author and they're talking
about you know the effects of poetry or
meaning of it think think about some
other things in our society what the
poet's did was to inform teach entertain
and they did so through through the
spoken word and drama and through to
certain extent music what would wouldn't
be like that
what would be like mini seriously
honestly be more like a miniseries what
about the Greek place those are life
forms or like actually some of the Greek
comedies are like sitcoms they we
actually got the sitcom idea from
ancient Greek later
music yeah well I was just gonna mention
you mentioned like yeah I this thing at
times if this is yes he's punished for
his actions and Troy I've done and again
an Athena protects them even though the
section actions or not proper so it's
kind of a big fish this country because
she's big and strong supposedly exactly
right so it's contradicted anything that
you see your watch it's kind of like
well we like people when they doing just
things and they get to get away with it
hey that's good for you you got away
with it but then again it becomes we
want you to be just so which one do we
you really choose yeah right this is
Canada well this would be proving the
case injustice is being celebrated right
and here is Plato the point the the
people who form our culture are giving
us bad messages notice they're not
giving us the message that you ought to
be just now for the sake of rewards and
punishments but because it's good for
you to be just not good in the sense of
bringing you some additional benefit but
it's good for you to actually have
justice to be the kind of person who
does the right thing and chooses not to
do what Plato saying is and this is
actually why he banishes the poets from
this city he's saying you're not getting
that so you can think this would be the
thing that sort of end up think about
whether that's the case in our in our
society whether you're getting
teachers and poets you know media or
whether maybe that doesn't apply it